juste guillaume genton montguillon
visiblement vous avez perdu du poids
ouais enfin je galère un peu non mais
c'est un oui j'ai perdu du poids vous
êtes magnifique guillaume n'avait pas
besoin de perdre deux sachets le joli
mais vous allez devoir peut-être changer
votre garde-robe royal et vêtements que
je mets plus j'ai stocké que j'ai stocké
ex je n'ai plus c'est vraiment trop bon
ouais bah ouais alors ça tombe bien
parce qu'on est allé s'occuper de votre
dressing chez vous pour vous faire un
petit peu regardants à bennwihr
conserver chez moi c'est bien chez vous
c'est votre meilleur pote à comment il
s'appelle des jeunes exactement qui nous
a donné les clés alors comme vous le
voyez on a récupéré vous mes vêtements
qui sont maintenant trop large pour vous
initier ou encore éviter de jeter tous
ses vêtements
deux pigeons et pour la bonne cause
on a posté une petite année on se
regarde et on a organisé un petit vide
dressing devant le suivant voilà tout ça
avec l'aide d'une personne ici présentes
regarde la braderie genton à qui le tour
tout ça fait pas vendre le vide greniers
j'entends la foire aux paillettes ça
part très vite
et croyez moi sur lui c'est monstrueux
mais sur notre petite soeur ça va lui
allait à ravir pas les 2 4 euros
c'est du sur mesure et moi peu importe
toutes les tailles vous vont 1500 euros
je vous le fais à 3 euros
tout ça pour 6 euros allez je te le
donne tes sa fatwa stone john
débarrasse-nous que ça et j'ai cloud
guillaume je vous le dis sachez que
cette somme va partir pour une
association avec l'association onco pour
les enfants hospitalisés atteints du
cancer on côté baissé la première chaîne
d'information d'orientation consacrée
aux concerts
onco keats avec des actions pour
réaliser aussi le rêve des enfants
touchés par la maladie
et c'est bientôt pâques on a décidé de
leur offrir 1000 euros de chocolat grâce
à daniel stoffel une distribution sera
organisé d'ailleurs dès lundi pour les
enfants hospitalisés au centre gustave
roussy situé à villejuif sachez que ça
rapporte et votre vide dressing 2714
euro si ses preneurs et sans salaire
pour avoir donné un instant du jeu bien
sûr que je vais redonner à guillaume et
qu'on va mettre nous pour l'association
bien entendu h2o non non non c'est
normal voilà à mon guillaume en tout cas
voilà c'était important de le faire